what up space fam golson here for anime
uproar and i'm back at it again to
discuss the latest developments in the
boruto story
on my last chapter review video i asked
if you guys wanted to keep seeing
boardroom reviews on this channel and
many of you said that you did
and even kept requesting this chapter
review in the comments of other videos
so here we are
if you want to keep these reviews going
show borto some love by smashing that
like button turn it blue
and sharing this video with your
cultured boruto friends
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell or you will miss future reviews as
you wait for the next chapter to drop
you can also check out my naruto slash
boruto playlist link in the description
for videos about the chihak clan the
hokage
and more feel free to leave suggestions
for other video ideas in the comments as
well
now without further ado let's jump into
it manga spoilers and all
this chapter is called time limit with
two exclamation marks so you know
there's going to be a sense of urgency
here
and that's something i like about the
bordeaux manga so far
it's fast paced and as a result it's a
real page turner we straight away pick
up where we left off with jiraiya's
clone
koji fighting ishiki amato explained
that this was a pointless battle last
chapter koji is not strong enough to win
he accomplished his mission when he got
ishiki to reincarnate in a non-kawaki
body
and thus kawaki's karma was erased
ishiki wanted to reincarnate in kawaki's
body when the karma was ready but amado
being the mad light he is managed to
thwart
this otozuki's plan however koji was not
told that he was fighting an impossible
battle
which brings us back to the fight koji
uses fire jutsu to no avail
he notices that ishiki's shrinking
powers are on a whole different level of
power
than before his reincarnation then we
see koji use another jiraiya move part
of the raging lion's mane
where his hair is manipulated in order
to bind an opponent
but the next thing we know ishiki in his
miniature form
is on koji's shoulder he got there
before koji even noticed
this is a classic moment that you'll see
in many shonen and we all know what's
happening
koji is trying everything he can think
of but it's pointless because the new
upgraded villain is too powerful
to even be phased ishiki is not even
trying he's like bored or even feels
pity as koji tries desperately
to do any damage at all not only does
ishiki tell koji that he cannot defeat
him
he says that he cannot defeat him ever
koji uses his hair to turn
himself into a giant porcupine hoping to
get or at least
feel where ishiki is but the otsutsuki
is too fast and he even flies as ishiki
says himself
his body is brimming with incredible
power but that incredible power is a
double-edged sword the power is so
strong that yes it makes him op
but it will also destroy his current
body soon because
it is an imperfect vessel here's the
time limit that was mentioned in the
title
according to ishiki there's only two or
three days left before the body is
destroyed
he needs to get kawaki's body back
before that
he praises a motto for being a sly fox
and for planning well
and i gotta hand it to amado yeah he's
kind of a jerk for tricking koji
but he's also pretty damn cool more on a
model later but for now koji says that
he's going to settle things here and now
which just
hurts my dry loving heart because this
dude stands no chance
and he's still acting like he doesn't
realize that ishiki has to explain to
koji what's up
and that amado expects naruto and sasuke
to take on ishiki ishiki straight up
says that amado had to flee
to naruto and sasuke because koji lacked
the power to take him down
and he says that in a pretty savage way
mind you like he was a god talking down
to an ant but the ototsuki tend to have
that arrogance
so nothing really strange there ishiki
tells koji
that he already served his purpose by
pulling him out of jigen
and making him reincarnate but koji
doesn't want to believe it
it seems like he views amado as his
friend and he doesn't even want to
consider the possibility that he lied to
him or tricked him
and the whole clone thing raises its own
philosophical questions
just as it did in pokemon the first
movie does a clone's life have less
value
and is it more dispensable than a
human's life even if the clone can feel
all of our human emotions because koji
is jiraya's clone
it's easy for us to view him as less
important than jariah but he has his own
complex life and sense of identity just
like any human
here's proof of that since he can
blindly trust in friendship
and feel betrayed very human traits
indeed then
ishiki being the cruel villain he is
tries to go after koji's sense of
identity
we all have a story or narrative that we
tell ourselves about ourselves and
seemingly koji thought of himself as a
heroic shinobi tool but ishiki says he
was nothing like that
but a mere pitiful sacrificial pawn here
he's not just dominating him physically
he's seriously messing with him on a
psychological level
we luckily get to see koji enter sage
mode which is pretty cool
he won't give up that easily whether his
own identity and existence
is in question or not again i respect
koji and i'm glad we got him in the
story i don't think it takes anything
away from jiraiya
rather it gives us a new character that
jaraya fans would probably enjoy
and that's coming from a guy whose
favorite character is jiraiya
we jump to amado who as i mentioned
before
has got to be one of the coolest
characters in boruto thus far he's not
even a ninja but he's so
calm cool and collected all the time and
even an otsutsuki
can't help but praise his intellect and
plans they agree to take in a motto and
give him some pretty reasonable terms
finally when shikamatu asks him to
disarm the bomb around his son's neck a
motto simply tells him it's a fake
it's just a decoration now i can't say i
saw this coming
but it makes perfect sense amado does
everything with a purpose
he explains how he used a real one the
one that blew up on the branch
so that they couldn't assume that the
one on chica died was fake
but he also knows that people don't want
to work and trust people
who have threatened the lives of their
children so he made sure that at the end
of the day
everyone knew that he didn't actually
threaten anyone's life
really he got the benefit without the
lasting consequences
a perfect win-win situation and he
pulled it off on shikamatu of all people
i gotta say it i find amado very
entertaining as a character we also get
some cool angles while motto is speaking
and explaining that they shouldn't rush
off to help koji
because ishiki wants kawaki so they
gotta protect him and stay close to him
at all costs
until ishiki's days run out otherwise
he'll use kawaki as a vessel and
complete his perfect reincarnation
the stakes are huge right now amato
tells them that ishiki is gonna come
and they should start evacuating the
village we know from the time skip that
we saw at the beginning of boruto that
the hidden leaf village will get
destroyed and the hokage faces too
so that actually could happen real soon
which is crazy to think about it might
get evacuated and stay destroyed for
years
before we get that final epic fight
between kawaki and boruto
and if that time skip scene is any
indication ishiki probably will get
kawaki as a vessel although there may be
a battle for control of the body within
like with naruto and kurama in the
beginning of naruto it's crazy that we
are finally starting to get crucial info
so that we can start to make more sense
of that time skip scene
for now though we get back to koji and
ishiki
koji is in sage mode and firing some
very impressive attacks
we get giant flame bombs a massive
rasengan
and more but it's no use ishiki puts a
stop to him without breaking a sweat
with the secret jutsu
daikokuten it lets him store what he
shrunk into another dimension
very kamui-esque and then summon it in a
battle at full size
he does this with pillars that take out
koji's arm and possibly his legs too
then the dude uses the opi jutsu to
summon a glass of wine
and then drink some what a mad lad he is
i do enjoy the idea of a shonen villain
just drinking some red wine
during a fight that's classy af again
ishiki brings up how koji
is skilled enough to know that he
couldn't hope to win
after the first exchange but he didn't
want to acknowledge amado's betrayal
ishiki points out how amado spotted that
weakness
using it he played koji just like he
played ishiki ishiki acknowledges that
they've been outmaneuvered by a motto
and again that's a big deal coming from
an otozuki
and here comes the moment of truth what
will happen to koji
was jiraiya brought back in a way just
to sacrifice himself again
as soon as we found out who he is i
desperately
hoped that that wouldn't happen and now
in this chapter ishiki starts to move
towards the kill
he asks koji if he has any last words
for our motto but he can't seem to hear
what the seemingly helpless koji is
saying then we get a truly epic moment
it turns out that koji was using
summoning and a giant toad pops up and
takes koji with him he makes eye contact
with ishiki
and he reverse summons away taking koji
with him
jiraiya lives in a sense and we will get
to see more of koji
i'm very very glad that they did it in
this way
because like i said last chapter it
would have sucked if he just came back
to sacrifice himself
immediately yet again as a jura fanboy
i'm glad we haven't seen the last of
koji ishiki calls koji a purposeless
stray dog which is a pretty deep
metaphor koji has no home and his one
friend betrayed him now he's also
heavily damaged but as someone who likes
his underdog
stories i look forward to seeing how
koji hopefully rises from the ashes like
a phoenix
and finds his place happiness and
purpose we'll definitely have to wait
for that
but i'm glad that there's hope at least
remember ishiki has a time limit so he's
not interested in chasing down koji
he even thinks that koji might want to
finish off a motto himself although
that's super uncharacteristic of koji
so i seriously doubt that the important
thing is he hasn't given up on life yet
ishiki in the meantime uses a space-time
ninjutsu to teleport somewhere
we jump back to naruto and boruto
arguing over whether boruto is going to
fight
naruto just says straight up that he'd
get in the way but
boruto won't give up saying that naruto
and sasuke lost against the weaker
version of ishiki
so how do they plan to win against an
even stronger version
it's a really crazy moment in boruto
when the two strongest shinobi look like
they're about to lose
sasuke mentions that he's ready to die
for the village as is naruto
he questions if borto is and borto is
speechless
he freezes proving that at this stage
he's not ready mentally or physically
for this fight
and then we learn that there is an
intruder and ishiki is just floating
over
konoha watching the ant-sized people
moving around below him this is how
fast-paced porto is
ishiki is not wasting any time we went
from an epic reveal of koji's true
identity
to a fight to koji barely escaping with
his life to ishiki immediately
teleporting to konoha
for what's sure to be the most serious
fight in boruto yet
where we'll probably see the strongest
characters go at it with their full
power
it's insane and i love it i'm on the
edge of my seat
and i'm almost shocked at how fast we're
moving here
clearly there was some potential
foreshadowing that sasuke especially and
even naruto might die
sasuke brought it up himself and if
kawaki
said after the time skip that he'll send
boruto where naruto
is that may mean that naruto is in
another dimension and that sasuke can't
rescue him
from it because sasuke is dead so there
are clues and hints right now that
sasuke specifically won't survive
but again those may be red herrings aka
fake clues
to make us worry and increased attention
i find it hard to believe that sasuke
would die
but maybe ishiki would weaken him enough
and take his eyes
so that he can't teleport through
dimensions we'll have to wait and see
anyways let me know what you thought of
this chapter and what you expect to
happen next who will die if anyone
will koji train borto during the time
skip the time skip is clearly
approaching
where boruto is going to have to mature
physically and mentally
and i'm excited to see boruto become
that very cool version of himself
that he is during the time skip scene if
you did enjoy this review and want to
keep the borato reviews coming the best
you can do is turn that like button blue
and share this video with your cultured
boruto friends
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell
or you will miss future boruto videos as
you impatiently wait a month for the
next chapter to drop
you can check out my growing naruto
slash portal playlist link in the
description
where i talk about the okay uchiha clan
and more
and don't forget to leave suggestions
for future video topics you're burning
up to see in the comments below
a very special thank you goes out to our
patrons over on patreon who help
make videos like this one possible first
and foremost i want to thank the one
tier patrons the ones who stand atop
all clans stephen ingrada alolan attempt
the world steelers acquire respect pate
heffa jonathan king brandon of viles
papa smurf the school bus king riser
emperor otaku ricardo martinez
thomas jones ken mono michael hyde and
jaden the vector controller
and our pro hero to your patrons the one
and only gilgamesh nothing but a fan
jason wilson kings eldris
anatoly kazatsky angel cruz cricket xp
joe stanton very gucci alicia actor
jessica
kayla fond hinokami and water bonnie
park zodiar12 rethu and day aura
kraken aurel's deadly saint and stern
hawkins thank you all
so much if you enjoy our work you can
support more by going over to
patreon.com anime pro and becoming a
patron today for as little as one dollar
if you do sell your gear name featured
in future videos alongside these amazing
people right here and you'll even get
access to our private patron only
discord where we talk about anime life
and of course thank memes
so check out patreon.com link in the
description if you're interested you can
also now join the youtube channel and
support more content that way if you
prefer whichever way you choose to
support us you can get the same great
benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you